あ~
小さい時じゃなくて、今
目が…
そう言われるのがすごく嫌でね
お父さん、パパと「くいね」とか見ないって
すごく嫌だったの小さい時
なんかちょっと目似てない?
うん、かもね
わかわれない
これ可愛い
すごい真剣としたもん
なんて思ってない?
待って歩かんとか
うん、ハイティさ
いろんなさ、お守りとか持ち歩いてるんだよ
お財布に
これね、こないたのいいね
うん
本当になんか、今頃になっても
やっと今頃になってた
大輝とも話ができるようになって
すごい嬉しいもん
大輝全然
もう一度に来てくれたり
あ、そうか
いや
えっと
うん
全然面白くないですけど
ちょっときれいなとこだからね
うん
都内なんだけど
だから
もしパパが
うまくに行くのよけたり
なんかしたら
そこに
3人で行けるなと思って
うんうん
うん
え、でも行きたいな
なんかあの
えひひおじいちゃんの
あの
きれいなお庭があるの
だけど
やばいからね
うん
いつも回れちゃうから
あんまり大変じゃなくて
行きゃ回るんだけどね
え、どこ?それって
あのー
六本木から歩けるところ
だから
六本木で待ち合わせればね
一番いいかな
え、行こう
え、もし
パパが来たら
じゃあ行こう
なんかそこ知らないんじゃないかな
どうだろう
普通はね
あのー
会員になってると
お昼とかみんな
あのー
ディスカンプってあるのね
やすくしてくれるんでね
会員じゃないんだけど
あのー
朝またちが
みんなさんいらっしゃったときに
みんなが入ってたからね
あのー
そう
っていうのを
聞かれるのに